hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tour if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com
the minimalists enjoy
minimalists
howdy what's your name my name is eliza
thanks for being here you guys this is
awesome
yeah so as some background of my
question i
i think my minimalist journey really
started near the beginning of covid and
i credit covid and all that time for
introspection and you know paradigm
shifts and everything with being
formative in me embracing minimalism
and so really got me thinking about
these life-changing experiences that we
have that could be global and universal
something like covid or it could be a
personal life-changing experience so my
question for either or both of you is
what are some insights that you have on
using these life-changing experiences to
shape our relationships whether it's
with our our things our money with
people etc
that makes me think of a new yorker
cartoon i saw one time of these two guys
they had uh there was like a guy in the
chair and he's all tied up and there's
these two robbers and like you can tell
they just took everything and like
they're just they're both carrying the
tv and they're on their way out the door
and they look they're looking back in
the guy and the caption said this is
your chance to start over don't screw it
up
that's good yeah so i i kind of wish we
all went through a near-death experience
every six months
i don't know if you've ever been through
one but i had i had um well the last
three years i had and i wrote about this
a bit in the book but the sort of nadir
of my life was as we were writing this
book summer of 2019 especially um
i got this we went down to brazil and um
i got this weird parasite we were down
there to speak and i got this parasite
and it just wrecked my life it caused
this horrible pain autoimmune pain i'd
wake up and just hideous hideous pain
every day for
over a year i've called it a three-year
near-death experience and while i'm
appreciably better now it's still still
the tail end of it and so
i am
well actually you know what let me read
a little bit from the book real quick
because the very beginning we um
we kind of talk about this
and i will say it better than i will
thank you return to text
all right this is from the uh preface of
the book the preface is called pandemic
preparation
the streets are a rumpant with uniform
men wielding titanic assault rifles
that's the first line in love people use
things
you know i'm not even gonna read that
whole thing because there's this whole
um thing about how when you first got
into the pandemic
um
how rough it was and how odd it was and
and um so you'll have to read that on
your own that's your homework for
tonight
but here we go
in an emergency not only must we
jettison the junk but many of us are
forced to temporarily deprive ourselves
of value-adding non-essentials
if we can do this we can discover what
is truly essential and then we can
evaluate we can eventually reintroduce
the non-essentials slowly in a way that
enhances and augments our lives but
doesn't clutter them with junk to
complicate matters essential ma
essential changes as we change what was
essential five years ago or even five
days ago
may not be essential now and so we must
continually question adjust let go
this is especially true during a crisis
where a week feels like a month a month
a lifetime
stuck in their homes people wrestled
with the fact that their material
possessions mattered less than they
originally thought the truth was all
around them
all the things collecting dust their
high school basketball trophies dusty
college textbooks and broken food
processors were never as important
as people
um
yada yada keep going
aha here we go
um
i don't know what the future holds
while i don't know what the future holds
i know we can emerge from this
uncertainty with a new normal one that
is predicated on intentionality and
community
rather than quote consumer confidence
to get there
we must simplify again we must clear the
clutter to find the path forward we must
find a deeper understanding beyond the
horizon
in the thick of the coronavirus crisis i
had a conversation with one of my
personal mentors a businessman named
carl widener who showed me the
characters for the chinese word for
crisis
way g
which signify danger way
and opportunity g
respectively while there are arguments
among linguists as to whether the
character for g actually means
opportunity the analogy is still apt a
crisis
a crisis exists
at the intersection of danger and
opportunity
in time there will undoubtedly be more
crises
in fact
you can guarantee it right that's why i
say that every six months it'd be great
if we had a near-death experience
because we're going to start questioning
we're going to stop being so apathetic
the problem the reason we're so busy is
because we have so much time
or we think we do yeah thanks um
return to text
uh even now as i write this a heightened
sense of danger lingers in the
atmosphere but opportunity is also in
the air surrounded by danger we have a
chance to as my friend joshua becker
says use these days to re-evaluate
everything
maybe we needed this
maybe this was our wake-up call
let us not waste this opportunity to
reevaluate everything to let go
to start anew
the best time to simplify was a decade
ago the second best time
is right now
[Applause]
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free